with the internet everything you could
be almost anywhere to have a business
and people really do shop around
listen it's easier to move out of the
city than it is to move in and that's a
problem
times are tough in Cleveland but it
wasn't always like this in the 1950s
business was booming and the Indians and
the Browns dominated those were the good
old days when Cleveland was going you
had the Westinghouse building he had
ever ready Kadri you know a million
printshop she had a million people they
used to be the sixth largest city in the
United States but that was back during
the heyday of steel and a lot of things
that were going right business-wise all
of that dried up in the 70s and it's
been a steady decline since then when
the jobs left the people followed today
Cleveland is the 41st largest city in
the US with a population of just four
hundred and thirty-five thousand if
Cleveland is to rebound it needs to be
the kind of place where businesses can
flourish how would you define the city's
business I would say the city's business
climate is robust Michael D Loya has a
different perspective as Cleveland's
Tech's are during Mayor Jane Campbell's
administration earlier this decade his
task was to convince high-tech firms to
relocate to Cleveland every time I would
go out to a tech company I can tell you
the same exact conversation I would have
and the idea was like hey I want you to
move into the city of Cleveland and the
response was you have to be out of your
mind though we had no staff or budget
Delia was able to offer companies
affordable and funky office space in
places like the Tyler elevator building
in three years Michael managed to learn
37 high-tech firms to Cleveland but that
was only the first step
part of Michael's job was to help these
companies navigate the city's regulatory
system what were the recurring obstacles
to developing well a lot of it was in
permitting and
and inspection - is not a fleet moving
organization
while Cuyahoga County has seen some
growth in high-tech and medical fields
it's lost more than a hundred thousand
manufacturing jobs in the past ten years
when we asked Clevelanders why
businesses weren't thriving they gave us
two reasons
taxes and red tape my only experience in
running a city is Sim City that the
computer game I know any raise taxes all
the students leave the city their entire
neighborhoods on the Eastside that are
completely abandoned and empty so the
property tax that the city once enjoyed
is gone
it lives unemployment tax you've got
companies leaving on mass Cleveland's
economic death spiral has coincided with
a gradual increase in state and local
taxes in the Buckeye State
in 1977 Ohio ranked 45th in the nation
in terms of its tax burden in 2008 it
ranks seventh today
Cleveland seems to be more focused on
tax revenue than it is on the overall
business climate whenever a new business
comes in the first thought is how much
tax revenue will that be yeah you know
yeah we talked about jobs - and it's
good for people to have jobs but even
then we look at the employees that would
come in for that business as expanding
the tax base Clevelanders not only pay a
lot of taxes they also have to deal with
an exceedingly complex tax system in
addition to federal and state income
taxes people in Northeast Ohio are
burdened by local sales and property
taxes as well as city payroll taxes that
average around two percent it is not the
sort of simple tax system that
encourages economic activity
for people to say that the climate is
anti-business don't know the word that I
represent don't know that this is people
that I'm proud to to you know take care
of this but most of the people aren't
saying that that people are anti
business but in that city hall throws up
a lot of roadblocks that are seeing the
gnosis of various business owners we've
talked to can ask you since so many of
the disgruntled business owners we spoke
to were afraid to appear on camera we
didn't give any names to Joe but we did
find a few brave souls who were willing
to speak candidly about the red tape and
Cleveland I think the city wants to work
with you I think some of the staff does
not work as may be expedient as the
private sector would like things to move
so it's I call it architecture by
persistence I had a timeframe as to when
I was going to start and when I was
going to finish of course that never
works out the way you anticipate but you
also would hope that when you're ready
to start demolition that if the city
doesn't tell you though you have to wait
for three more buns for us to approve
your ear plan this perk guy across the
street from me went there to get a sign
put up on his building in a sign on a
brick building in a in an area that's
now deserted well who cares he goes to
this design review thing and they want
them to bring a drawing bring another
sign try this sign it's a sign in
Cleveland you can need a permit for a
pool table or if you want to have a DJ
spin records in a restaurant on a Friday
night that's not the sort of environment
that's welcoming to business and that's
welcoming to entrepreneurship any
investment that comes in will end up
going through a suburb anyway because
who wants to deal with these people
this is the Board of Zoning Appeals
where many of the battles between
business people in City Hall are fought
in Cleveland like many other older
cities the way you get things done is to
lick the boots of the city's politicians
in the hope that they'll champion your
cause and really my job is to be the
needle and thread until we get it done
did you talk about a case where you
helped the small business cut through
red tape just so a businessman could get
on with shirt buying and selling stuff
Morgan linen is the only linen company
left in the city of Cleveland the
neighbors agreed to this change in
zoning so he could expand some parking
lot to pull the cars off the street you
could actually hire more people you
never only had to navigate the city's
building in the housing department he
also had to navigate the sewer
department because of the irrigation he
had a navigate the county because of the
taxation and the way they were billing
and he had to navigate how he was going
to consolidate his Lots so that the
zoning would be in total and not just
for one he was trying to do this for the
last decade and we got involved and
we're actually able to help him in about
a year and a half there's got to be a
better way we went to Houston a city
without a state or local income tax
where we spoke to businessman Dan Bello
of at Houston's business climate Bello
is the chairman of the Greater Houston
partnership we have 29 I think fortune
500 companies headquarter here in
Houston but you know what the majority
of the employment base comes from small
businesses people who employ less than a
hundred people and those are the people
you really need to support you need to
make it easy for them to do business you
need to make it affordable from a tax
point of view the assumption in Houston
is you should be able to do what you
want to do unless it's a really good
reason why you shouldn't do it in many
cities it's completely the opposite you
shouldn't be able to do anything unless
you kiss X number of rings or X number
of tokus as you know depending how you
want to put it
geordie blonde shea is the general
manager of a brand new bee Ventura
manufacturing plant in Houston where
companies producing mainly parts for the
automotive sector it's all turned parts
we have screw machines around 20 in
Spain and here we are planning to have
like three or four the first year
Jordi's barcelona based company could
have set up shop anywhere in the US
including a traditional manufacturing
town like Cleveland but the company
chose Houston before coming here we get
the student from the Chamber of Commerce
of Barcelona and they decide that
Houston was a good area because they
told us that it was iffy very easy to
just set up the company in fact Jordi
and his colleagues were able to complete
all the paperwork to set up shop in
Houston in a single afternoon so really
that's something that it took me because
well it's many of you want to set up a
company you need to almost like five
Mons or six months it's not that easy
why do 60,000 people move to Houston
each year they come for the opportunity
and they stay because if you believe
publications like dwarves and Kiplinger
Houston is a great place to live work
and play why do we keep adding jobs why
are you here talking to us something's
working right so what can Cleveland
learn from a city like Houston the best
thing for our place like cable and to
get business in there and most of all if
they want international business to go
there they have to make things easier
Cleveland's not going to attract people
because of its beaches or because of its
mild winters it's gonna attract people
if this is a place where they can reap
returns on their investments and and
make a good life for themselves
it's a bottom-line thing for businesses
they want lower taxes and less red tape
simple as that
you